AI never sleeps and this week has been
absolutely
insane. The best open-source video
generator with audio just dropped. We
also have not one but two
state-of-the-art open-source image
editors just like Nano Banana. We have
not one but two realtime video
generators that can just run on a single
GPU. Alibaba continues to release even
smaller models of Quen, and these ones
can run just on your smartphone or other
Edge devices. Nvidia releases an AI that
can fix and add more details to 3D
scenes in real time. This AI takes a
single video and turns it into a 360°
video, which you can view at any angle.
We have a ton of ridiculous humanoid
robot demos and a lot more. So, let's
jump right in. First up, this AI is
pretty cool. So, it's called Kiwiedit,
and this is an open-source video editing
tool. So, it's just like Nano Banana,
but for video. Here are some examples.
You can turn an existing video into any
style you want. So, for example, here we
can turn this into sketch style. Or
here's another example where we can turn
this video into cartoon animation or we
can turn this into watercolor style. You
can also input reference images. So for
example here we can input this reference
image and here is our original video and
we can get it to replace the background
with this image and here is our result
or here's another example where we can
replace the background with this image
and here's yet another example. Now you
can also add stuff to an existing video.
For example, you can get the boy to wear
this hat or conversely you can also
remove anything in a video. For example,
here we're prompting it to remove this
person from the video. And you can also
upload a photo of any object and add
that to a video. For example, we can get
this girl to wear these sunglasses. And
how this works is they combined a
multimodal LLM for understanding
instructions with a video diffusion
transformer model, which is in charge of
actually generating and editing the
video. Now, if you compare this to other
open-source video editors, then you can
see that on average, this one performs a
lot better than other ones I featured on
my channel like Vase and Lucydit. Now,
if you compare this with closed source
video editors like Cling01, then Cling01
is still the best. It still beats QEdit.
Anyways, the awesome thing is if you
scroll up to the top of the page,
they've already released everything. So,
if you click on this GitHub repo and you
scroll down a bit here, it contains all
the instructions on how to download and
run this locally on your computer. Plus,
they've also released the code on
training and evaluation. Now, if I go on
HuggingFace and inspect one of these
models, it is quite large. So, the total
size is 20 GB in size. You'll need a
higherend consumer GPU to run this.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Also this week,
Tencent releases a really powerful image
editor just like Nano Banana. So it's
called HY Woo. And this is an image
editor that is especially good at close
swapping and style transfer. Here are
some examples. You can plug in this
initial image as well as these reference
images and get Elon to wear these
costumes like this. You can see it's
able to preserve the details of both
reference images very well. Or here's
another example where we can upload this
image and get her to wear all these
different costumes from these reference
images. And as you can see, it's able to
apply this clothes swap very seamlessly.
And then here are some other examples of
applying an outfit from another
reference photo. So how this works is it
turns the reference images and your text
prompt into special code and then
instantly makes a tiny Laura from it.
And then it injects this Laura or this
fine-tuned model into the native image
editor to generate your final image. And
this makes the results a lot more
accurate and consistent. Now, here's the
win rate between HY Woo and some other
leading open-source and closed source
image editors. So, as you can see, for
the open- source ones like Quen Imageit
and Long Cat Imageit and Flux 2, HY Woo
wins most of the time. And even for the
closed Cream 4.5 and GPT image 1.5, HY
Woo seems to win most of the time.
However, it still loses to Nanopanana 2
and NanoPanana Pro. Note that this is
open source. They've released this
already. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo and you scroll down a bit here, it
contains all the instructions on how to
download and run this locally on your
computer. However, note that the base
model is quite large. So, you need like
8 * 40 GB or 4 * 80 GB of VRAM, which
I'm sure most of you don't have.
However, if you scroll up to the top
here, it looks like they are planning to
release a distilled checkpoint, which
should be a bit smaller. Anyways, if
you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. Also, this week, this
AI is super cool. It's called Cube
Composer, and this can take a normal
video shot from just one camera and turn
it into a full 360° video that you can
view in any direction, like for virtual
reality. Plus, this can also upscale the
damn video to 4K resolution. So, on the
site, they actually give you some
interactive demos of the 360° videos
that this AI was able to generate. So,
here I'm playing around with this
example. And then here's another example
of a snowy field. The details are pretty
good. Now, there are some distortions
and errors with this generation. It's
not perfect, but it's still pretty
impressive that it's able to take just
one video and convert it into a 360°
scene like this. And then here's an
example of a highway. And again, it's
able to even guess, you know, what the
back of the scene would look like. Now,
if you compare this to other competitors
like Argus, you can see that the quality
is a lot worse. Here's the same
snowfield example with Argus. This is
absolutely awful. Here's another
competitor called Viewpoint, and this
looks even worse. And then here's the
highway example with Viewpoint. This
just looks awful. So, at least comparing
to these two competitors, then Cube
Composer is by far the one with the best
quality. All right, so here's how it
works. It uses a diffusion model that
inspects your video one piece at a time,
and then it breaks it down into a 360
degree sphere with six main components.
Each generates a face of the 3D scene at
a time in short chunks. And then it uses
this context pool with sparse attention
to remember past and future parts and
also nearby faces or segments of the 3D
scene so that everything blends in
seamlessly. And then it also adds some
special stuff like cube aware positional
encoding and also some padding and
blending to make it look even more
smooth and seamless. The awesome thing
is they've already released the code to
this. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo at the top and you scroll down a
bit here, it contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. Anyways,
if you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. Also, this week we
have a new top open-source image editor.
So, it's called Fire Red Image Edit 1.1.
The previous version 1.0 was also really
good, but here they've upgraded this to
be even better. Here are some examples.
So, you can take this original image and
change the background and her outfit and
her pose, but it's able to keep her face
consistent the whole time. Or here's
another example where we can take this
baby and change the pose in the
background and generate a completely new
photo of this. But notice that it keeps
the face consistent. And then here's
another example where we can keep his
face plus his outfit consistent the
entire time. You can also upload a ton
of different reference images and merge
them all together into sue one photo
like this. So, it works just like nano
banana. Here are some more examples
where we can get this woman and get her
to wear all these items and it's able to
seamlessly generate an image from that.
Or here's yet another example. Notice
that both this dress plus these shoes
are really complex in detail, but it's
able to accurately render this in its
generation. This is a semantic image
editor. So, you can just prompt it on
what you want to edit. Here's an example
where we can take an original image and
prompt it to add different makeup styles
to this face. Here's another cool
example where we have this reference
photo plus this reference photo of a
poster. And let's say we want to add
this style of text to this photo. Well,
it's able to accurately apply this font
like this. Or here's another example
where it can accurately apply the font
from this reference image onto here. And
if you look at these benchmark scores,
as you can see, this new Fire Red 1.1
even beats the leading open-source image
generators like Quen ImageEdit as well
as Longcat Image Edit. So, currently, at
least according to these benchmarks,
Fire Red ImageEdit 1.1 is the best
open-source image editor. For some of
these benchmarks, it even surpasses Nano
Banana Pro, which is in yellow. The
awesome thing is, as with the previous
Fire Red models, they've already open
sourced this. Now, if you click on files
and versions, note that this is like
almost 60 GB in size. So, unfortunately,
you're not going to be able to fit this
on most consumer GPUs, but hopefully
there's going to be some GGUFS or
quantized versions of this which will be
more compressed. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this AI is also pretty
crazy. So, it's called Helios, and this
can generate long videos in real time.
Here it says this can generate 19.5
frames per second video on a single H100
GPU, and this can generate videos up to
a minute long. Now, I featured several
real-time AI video generators in the
past, but all of them were pretty bad
quality. This is actually the best
quality one I've seen so far. Now, yes,
this still requires an H100, which I'm
sure most of you do not have, but it's a
good start. I mean, the fact that this
can generate almost 20 frames per second
of this quality with just one GPU is
already really impressive. And I'm sure
it's only going to get faster and more
efficient in the coming months. Now,
given that this is real time, the
quality isn't as great as like the top
models out there, which are a lot
sharper. You can still see some like
noticeable noise and lack of detail, but
it's pretty good. And then here's an
example of the terminal as it generates
a video. So you can see how fast this
is. And this is incredibly fast. As you
can see here, it takes like less than 2
seconds to generate over 30 frames. I
featured a ton of these methods on my
channel before, such as like reward
forcing, self-forcing, and as you can
see, in terms of frames per second, the
distilled version of Helios is really
quick. It's among the top out there at
19.5 frames per second. Not the fastest,
but the ones that beat it are really bad
in quality. And notice that there are
only 1.3 billion parameters whereas
Helios is a lot larger. So especially if
you look at this graph and you compare
the video quality of long real-time
video generation, notice that Helios
outperforms the other methods. And if
you look at this graph where you compare
Helios with other top video generators
that are not real time, such as 1 2.2,
long video, and LTX2, you can see that
it's actually on par with some of the
top models. Anyways, if you scroll up to
the top of the page, they've released
everything already. So, if you click on
this GitHub repo and you scroll down a
bit here, it contains all the
instructions on how to install and run
this locally on your computer, they
offer a ton of different pipelines where
you can run this. Plus, they also
released the training code for this as
well. Anyways, if you're interested in
reading further, I'll link to this main
page in the description below. Also,
this week, we have this really cool
project called enhancing spatial
understanding in image generation via
reward modeling. In simple terms, this
is basically a framework that improves
image generators so they can better
understand spatial relationships in your
prompt. For example, if you add words
like left or right of something, behind
something, above, below, then for most
image models out there, it's not able to
actually capture the position of
everything that you specify. But after
adding this framework, it's a lot
better. So here are some examples. Let's
say here's the text prompt. In a dining
room, a long table holds three candles
arranged in a line. From the viewer's
perspective, the tallest candle is on
the left. Medium is in the center.
Shortest is on the right. We have a bowl
of fruit sit sitting behind the center
candle aligned with it. And then we have
two plates placed in front of the line
of candles. One aligned with the tallest
and one aligned with the shortest. And
then a painting hangs on the wall
centered above the bowl. Now, here is
the generation from just the raw flux
model. And as you can see, the candles
aren't arranged in a line. Plus, the
tallest candle is not on the left. the
bull is not behind the center candle.
There are just a lot of errors with this
generation. However, if you use this new
model, you can see that it actually
follows your prompt exactly. The candles
are arranged in a line. We have the
tallest candle on the left. There is a
bowl of fruits behind the center candle.
There is a plate in front of the left
and the right candle. Plus, a painting
is also centered and behind the center
candle. It follows this perfectly. Or
here's another example. Here we have an
armchair faces a small round table. A
floor lamp sits behind the chair aligned
with its back rest center. A teacup sits
on the table's left side. Small plate of
cookies sits on the table's right side,
etc., etc. Now, again, here is the
original image from Flux, but as you can
see, the lamp isn't actually behind the
back rest of the chair. The cup isn't on
the table's left side, and the cookies
aren't on the right side. Whereas for
this new method, you can see the lamp is
indeed centered behind the back rest of
the chair plus the items on the table
are also arranged properly. Or here's
another example where we have an orange
cone centered behind a car. A backpack
lies on the ground to the car's left
rear tire. A water bottle stands to the
car's right rear tire. And then a map is
spread on the car trunk lid center. A
jacket is draped over the trunk's right
edge. So you can see here the jacket is
wrong. The map is not centered. Plus the
water bottle is not near the right tire.
Whereas for this new method, it got
everything correct. So how they made
this is they first created this huge
data set with over 80,000 pairs
comparing correct versus incorrect
spatial arrangements. For example, here
is the prompt and here's the correct
answer. But they also intentionally
edited the image to make it wrong. And
then afterwards they trained a reward
model using this data set of correct and
incorrect pairs. And afterwards this
framework now understands you know the
spatial arrangement of objects based on
your prompt a lot better. The awesome
thing is if you scroll up to the top of
the page and you click on this GitHub
repo here it says we are planning to
release the data set and the model
weights. So stay tuned for that. If you
really care about you know the spatial
arrangement of objects in your images
then this might be a good framework to
use. Anyways, if you're interested, I'll
link to this main page in the
description below. Also, this week, Bite
Dance isn't done cooking yet. So, they
also released this crazy tool called
Spectrum. And this is a way to speed up
AI image and video generation by
predicting future steps instead of
actually computing them. So, you can
basically apply spectrum on top of any
existing video or image workflow. So for
example here they applied it to Hunyan
video to get it to speed up the
generation by like 3.5 times without any
loss in quality. And then instead of
video you can also apply spectrum to an
image generator like flux to also speed
up the generation by 3.5 times. So
here's a comparison with its image
generations compared to other
acceleration methods. Spectrum is on the
far right and as you can see with the
same prompt the quality is pretty much
the same as the original flux generation
but it's just that spectrum is like 4.7
times faster even faster than the other
acceleration methods which introduce a
ton of errors in the generation. And
then here is a video generation
comparison. So on the left is the
original video generated with Hunyan
video at 50 steps. In the middle is this
new spectrum generated with only 14
steps. So it's a 3.5 times increase. And
then on the right is another
acceleration called Taylor's Seir. But
as you can see, the quality of this
competitor is a lot worse. The colors
are a lot more saturated. Whereas for
Spectrum, it's really hard to tell this
apart from the original generation, even
though it's a lot faster. And then
instead of Hunan Video, here's another
test using Juan 2.1. Again, Spectrum is
in the middle. A competitor, Taylor
Seir, is on the right. And it just has
way too many errors. As you can see
here, Spectrum looks almost the same as
the original video. So the quality is
great, but you can generate this like
3.5 times faster. If you're curious on
how this works, it basically uses a math
technique called the chbbyef polomials
to model how features change over time.
And it uses this to forecast future
steps without spending more compute. So
that makes it a lot faster, but without
degrading the quality much. The awesome
thing is they've already released the
code to this. So, if you click on this
GitHub repo and you scroll down a bit
here, it contains all the instructions
on how to download and run this locally
on your computer. Note that it works for
both text to image for a ton of
different models like Flux and SDXL as
well as text to video for Hunen and one
2.1. Anyways, if you're interested in
reading further, I'll link to this main
page in the description below. I've been
covering the best image and video
generators, and it can get very
overwhelming. Fortunately, Higsfield,
the sponsor of this video, brings
everything together all in one place.
They just released Soul Cinema Preview,
their most cinematic in-house photo
model yet. Built specifically for
creators and AI filmmakers, it produces
cinema grade images with rich textures,
deep mood, and spontaneous quality. This
works seamlessly with Soul ID, so you
can make your own character and generate
images from that. It also works great
with Soul Hex for precise color control
over your generations. Think commercial
campaigns, AI film making, and music
videos, anything that needs to feel
high-end. And right now, it comes with
10,000 free generations on Pro Plus
plans. So, it's a great time to jump in.
If you want to try Soul Cinema Preview,
as well as the other top image and video
generators out there, all in one
platform, definitely check out
Higsfield. Click the link in the
description below to try it out today.
Next up, this AI is pretty crazy. So,
Bite Dance just built an AI system that
automatically writes faster GPU code for
AI. It's called CUDA agent. And this is
quite technical. So, let's break this
down in simple terms. You see, most
modern AI systems like GPT or image
models, video generators, they all run
on GPUs. And GPUs use special programs
called kernels that execute code in
parallel really fast. So a kernel is
basically a program that runs on a ton
of GPU cores at once, but these are
really hard to write and optimize. So
here they've created a tool called CUDA
agent, which not only writes out this
GPU code, but it also tests it and
measures its speed and improves the
quality until it becomes faster and
faster. So it's like an AI agent that's
optimized for writing code for GPUs. And
the output of this CUDA agent is
actually ridiculously good. So here are
some metrics for your reference. Here
they're comparing it with some of the
top models out there including Gemini 3
Pro and Opus 4.5. But as you can see
this new CUDA agent is even better at
writing GPU code across all these
metrics. So the correct rate of the GPU
code as well as all these speed metrics.
You can see by far it's better than the
other models. Now the awesome thing is
they've released everything already. So
if you click on this GitHub repo and you
scroll down a bit here, it contains the
entire data set that they used to train
this agent. And then here is the entire
agent workflow. So you can download and
try this yourself as well. This is very
technical, but it's quite a big deal if
you're into optimizing CUDA kernels to
make AI models run faster. So if you're
interested, I'll link to this main page
in the description below. Next up, this
AI is super helpful. So it's called UNIA
and this is a single AI model that
understands all types of 3D point cloud
data. Now traditionally you need to
build separate models for scanning
different types of 3D data. For example,
self-driving LAR scans would have a
separate model from indoor room scans
which would also be separate from like
satellite or remote sensing data. But
here is one encoder that works across
all of them. And this allows the same
model to be used for many things like
robotics, autonomous driving, virtual
reality, spatial reasoning, 3D
segmentation, and more. So, as you can
see here, it can work with a ton of
different types of point cloud data.
This is a unified model that can convert
any type of 3D point cloud data,
including outdoor LAR data or indoor
scans or CAD models, and basically
encode them to be used for downstream
tasks. The awesome thing is they've
already released this. So if you click
on this GitHub repo and you scroll down
a bit here, it contains all the
instructions on how to install and run
this locally on your computer. Note that
this is quite a small model. So if I
click on the hugging face repo, this is
only like 550 megabytes in size.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Also, this week
we have another video editor called
Freeedit. And this is quite interesting.
So, this edits videos by changing the
first frame and then having the AI
propagate those changes throughout the
rest of the video. For example, we can
change the background from this desert
hill into some sand castles and that
would just be the first frame. Now, what
freeit does is it then applies this
background change to the rest of the
video. Or here's another example where
we can take the first frame of this
video and turn the cart to red and then
freeit would make this car red
throughout the rest of the video. Now,
if you compare this with other video
editing methods like go with the flow or
ITVEdit, etc., notice that this new one
freeedit just performs a lot better.
Everything is a lot more consistent.
Here's another example for your
reference. Now, how this works is it
uses something called editing aware RE
injection. So as the diffusion model is
generating the video, you can see that
it adds these RE blocks which basically
uses optical flow to track the edited
regions across frames and then it
adaptively controls how much of the
original video gets edited with the new
features. Unfortunately for this one,
they haven't released the code or
anything yet. So all we have is a
technical paper on this, but if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Also this week we have yet
another real time video generator. It's
called Real Wonder. And this lets you
generate real-time videos showing what
happens when you apply a force to
objects in a certain direction. So for
example, here we can adjust how this
object would move in this water in real
time as dictated by the direction of the
orange arrow. Or here's another example
where we can adjust the orange arrow to
the right and here's what happens. Or
here's another example where we can
apply wind in the direction of this
orange arrow to these clothes. And
here's what happens. Here's another
example where if we apply force in one
direction, the objects would move in
that direction in real time. You can
even apply multiple forces. So, for
example, one to the left and one to the
right, and it would still work. Now,
here are some specs. This can run on 13
frames per second on a single H200 GPU
at 480p resolution. Now, of course, most
of you don't have an H.200. This is
still too bulky to run on a consumer
GPU, but it's a nice proof of concept.
Now, if you scroll up here, the awesome
thing is they've released the code to
this already. So, if you click on this
GitHub repo and you scroll down a bit
here, it contains all the instructions
on how to download and run this locally
on your computer. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this AI is really
helpful for creating ads. So, it's
called Hi-Fi Paint, and this seamlessly
inserts products into photos of people
holding them. So, for example, let's say
you have this product image and this
person. Well, you can insert the product
into this person seamlessly like this.
Or here's another example. You can
insert this product into this photo like
this. or this product into this photo
like this. Now, we already have a ton of
image editors that can do this like Coin
Image Edit and Nano Banana, but this one
they claim is Specialized to do this
particular task. So, in theory, it
should preserve the accuracy and
consistency of the product even better.
So, for example, here's a comparison
with this new Hi-Fi in Paint with other
methods like Ace++ or Insert Anything or
Flux Context, which is pretty old. So,
it seems like they're cherry-picking
here, but nevertheless, you can see that
this new Hi-Fi inpaint is the best in
terms of preserving the product
accuracy. Here's another example where,
as you can see, Hi-Fi inpaint is a lot
better at preserving the look of the
product. Here are some other examples
for your reference. So how this works is
they use a regular diffusion transformer
model to generate the image but they
added a special component called this
shared enhancement attention which
refineses the product details using
highfrequency maps. Now if you scroll up
to the top here they have released a
GitHub repo and here it says we will
release the code data set and model
after internal review so stay tuned for
that. Anyways, if you're interested in
reading further, I'll link to this main
page in the description below. Also,
this week, Alibaba continues to release
some really cool models. So, last week I
mentioned that they released Quen 3
medium. These are a family of
medium-sized models. So, one is 27
billion parameters, another is a mixture
of experts with 35 billion parameters,
but only 3 billion are active when you
use it. Well, you can run those on like
high-end consumer GPUs, but what if you
don't even have a high-end GPU? Well,
this week they released even smaller
Quen 3.5 models. So, this week we have
Quen 9 billion parameters, 4 billion
parameters, 2 billion, and even.8
billion parameters. If I click on this8
one, it's only 2 GB in size. So, you can
even fit this comfortably on just a CPU
or even a mobile device. And if I click
on the 9 billion one, this is like 20 GB
in size, but with some compression or
quantization, you can probably
comfortably fit this on a regular
consumer GPU. Now, here's the cool thing
about these small models. So, the
leftmost columns are Quen 3.5, 9B, and
4B. And as you can see, it's on par with
some even larger models like Quen ADB,
as well as some closed source flash
models like GPT5 Nano and Gemini 2.5
Flash Light. This is extremely
impressive. So for like instruction
following, it does incredibly good. Same
with graduate level science questions.
Same with Harvard level mathematics and
also multilingual knowledge. It's
especially good at MMU Pro, which is
like visual understanding and reasoning.
So, anyways, if you are looking for the
best but smallest model to fit on a
low-end GPU or on your mobile phone or
other edge devices, these smaller Quen
3.5 models might be a good option for
you. Anyways, all of them are listed on
this Quen 3.5 collections page. So, if
you're interested, I'll link to this
page in the description below. Also,
this week, we have a new open-source
video generator with audio natively
built in. So, it's called LTX 2.3, and
this is incredibly powerful. Here are
some examples.
Audio has been greatly improved.
Dialogue sounds especially clean.
>> Are you sure this is a good idea? You're
going to love it.
>> Now, this is a super flexible tool. This
can take in just a text prompt or also
an image to use as the first frame or
basically image to video. Plus, this can
also take in audio which you want to
use. Now, this can do up to 20 seconds
and up to 4K in resolution. Plus, the
biggest upgrade for me is that now
version 2.3 can do vertical videos as
well, whereas for the previous version,
it can only do horizontal videos. And
here they claim that version 2.3 is
sharper in detail. It's better at
following your prompt. It's better
consistency if you use image to video.
Plus, the audio is a bit cleaner. Now,
if you want to get this installed on
your computer, don't worry. I'm working
on a full tutorial which will come out
next. I was actually planning to release
the tutorial, but GPT 5.4 also came out
on the same day, so I decided to
prioritize that instead. For now, if
you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. All right, so that
brings me to GPT 5.4, 4, which was
actually released the same day as LTX
2.3. This is OpenAI's most capable and
efficient Frontier model yet. And this
is so good at reasoning, agentic coding,
doing regular office tasks like working
with spreadsheets, docs, and PowerPoint
presentations. Plus, it's also
incredibly good at physics and math.
Anyways, I already did a full review
video on it, so I'm not going to repeat
too much here. definitely see this video
to get a sense of all the cool things
that it can do. Next up, this AI is
pretty cool. So, it's called Artifixer,
and this enhances and fixes 3D
reconstructions. So, here are some
examples. We currently have a ton of
different methods to reconstruct a 3D
view from just a few photos of that
scene. However, if you have just a few
photos, like two or three of the scene,
then it's really hard to construct an
entire 3D scene from that. So these are
called sparse 3D reconstructions because
you don't really have a lot of data. So
there's a lot of missing details in the
scene as you can see from these three
different models. Well, this new
Artifixer basically takes in these
reconstructions and uses diffusion
models to enhance the details and fix
all these issues. So after plugging it
through Artifixer 3D, you can see that
the scene looks a lot more coherent and
detailed. And then here's an indoor
example of this bonsai tree. Notice the
floor and the background is very messy
with a ton of different items, but it's
able to make this super coherent and fix
all these issues. Here's another really
difficult example of this messy counter.
And again, as you can see, Artifixer is
able to fill in any missing data, fix
any artifacts, and generate a very
coherent 3D render of this scene. Here's
another indoor example of a really messy
living room. And again, Artifixer 3D is
the only one that is able to generate
this 3D scene smoothly. Here's another
comparison. And note that from the
original image data of the 3D scene, you
can see like the background isn't really
captured properly, especially if you
look at the first two columns. So, it's
really hard for the AI to guess the
background. Artifixer is able to fill in
the background incredibly seamlessly,
much better than the other competitors.
Now, while this is a really incredibly
useful model for now, that's all the
information we have. There's no
indication whether they will open source
this or not, there's not even a GitHub
repo. But if you are interested in
reading further and checking out more
examples, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Now, actually,
similar to the previous tool, Nvidia
also teases their own 3D enhancer. So,
it's called diffusion harmonizer, and
this also fixes visual artifacts in
real-time simulations. So, here's one
example. Here's a frame in the video
where you can just randomly paste in
these cars from somewhere else. You can
see that they're not really blending in
the scene, but after plugging it through
diffusion harmonizer, all three cars are
able to blend in seamlessly with this
environment. It's able to change the
white balance, the colors, the shadows,
etc. All right, here's an example where
on the left again, we just paste in some
random cars. They don't even have
shadows. Everything looks very fake. But
after plugging it through diffusion
harmonizer, you can see that this scene
looks very seamless, as if these cars
are actually driving on this road.
Here's another example where on the left
is just a simulation. And you can see
this looks really fake, but after
plugging it through diffusion
harmonizer, it adds shadows to the cars
and everything just looks a lot more
real. Now, there are other alternatives
for you to kind of edit and enhance a
simulation, but as you can see, they're
pretty bad. They're probably
cherry-picking here. I mean, like SDEit
based on stable division 3 is extremely
old, but nevertheless, you can see that
this new method from Nvidia just looks a
lot more realistic. Now, if you scroll
up to the top, right now they've only
released a technical paper. There's no
indication whether they will open source
this or not, but if you're interested in
reading further, I'll link to this main
page in the description below. All
right, next up, this AI is incredible.
So, it's called Omni Extreme, and this
controls humanoid robots and allows them
to perform some incredibly athletic and
extreme movements like break dancing,
flips, and martial arts. So, after
applying this framework to the robot,
you can see that it's able to do some
incredible stuff like jumping, dancing,
and flipping. I mean, look at that. You
can see here it's doing like two
consecutive back flips, and now it's
break dancing. I mean, this is crazy.
And everything looks so fluid and
natural. Here are some other break
dancing examples. You can even do like
high-speed flips like this. And notice
that it's able to do all of these kicks
in one continuous scene. And then here
are some other examples of some
high-speed flips. He could even flip
from just jumping with one leg, which is
crazy. Here you can see it trying to do
a handstand and balancing. And then here
is another incredibly impressive
balancing act. This is really hard for a
humanoid robot to pull off. Here's how
this works in simple terms. So they
first broke this down into a
pre-training phase where the robot
learns each individual movement in
simulation. So they use what are called
motion tracking experts which are
basically teachers that are really good
at imitating one kind of hard movements
such as break dancing or kung fu or
flips. And then these experts are
combined into one unified base policy
using a technique called flow matching.
So this creates a really highcapacity
brain that already knows how to roughly
do a huge variety of these extreme
motions. However, to make it actually
work on the real robot, you also need
post-training. So, here in the post-
training, this policy is basically
frozen. But they also add another
lightweight residual policy. And this
part makes sure the moves don't destroy
the real motors or make the robot lose
balance or violate any physics limits.
So, this post-training part basically
allows the robot to execute these moves
fluidly and naturally without falling
down or breaking things. The awesome
thing is if you scroll up to the top of
the page, they've actually released the
code to this. So on their GitHub repo,
if you scroll down a bit here, it says
they've already released the checkpoints
and the evaluation code. So here are all
the instructions on how to download and
test this out yourself. If you happen to
have a Unitere lying around. Anyways, if
you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. Also, this week, this
AI is pretty interesting. It's called
track for world and this takes a normal
video and figures out exactly where
every single pixel moves in 3D space
over time. So for example here, let's
say we take this parkour video. Well, we
can plug it through this AI and it's
able to track all the pixels and how
they move in this scene. Or here's a
skiing example. And again, it's able to
track all the pixels of the scene as
they move over time. And then here is a
swing example. So from just one video,
this is able to create like 3D paths for
every point of the scene plus the basic
3D shape of the scene. So you can
potentially use this data to reconstruct
this in 3D. And you can also use this
for very accurate motion tracking. So
here's an example of a video and we can
plug it through this AI to very
accurately track the motion of this
person. Or here's another example. And
then here's an example of a 3D scene
reconstructed from this video where it
tracks the moving characters. So how
this works is it uses one big vision
transformer modeled to understand the
whole scene at once and then it also
uses other components to predict the 2D
and 3D motion together to combine them
smoothly into one coherent scene. Now on
this page they have released an
interactive demo for you to try this
out. Also they've released the GitHub to
this already. So, if you scroll down a
bit here, it contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. Anyways,
if you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. And that sums up all
the highlights in AI this week. Let me
know in the comments what you think of
all of this. Which piece of news was
your favorite? And which tool are you
most looking forward to trying out?
Thanks for watching, and if you enjoyed
this video, remember to like and
subscribe. And if you've made it to
here, I've got a treat for you. I'm
partnering with Nvidia to give away an
RTX 5090 GPU around their GTC 2026
event. With this, you can easily run AI
tools locally on your computer. Here's
how to enter. Simply click the link in
the description to register and attend
at least one GTC 2026 session, which
will be on March 16th to 19th. You can
attend virtually or in person. Here are
some of my favorites. Jensen Huang's
keynote is an obvious one, but this one
on humanoid robots at scale as well as
this one on openw world models are also
on my watch list. Again, make sure you
sign up for GTC using the link in the
description below. And then afterwards,
fill out the form and you're good to go.
It's totally free to enter.